We've seen how adding just simple color textures can vastly improve the look of
a model. GPUs are very much optimized to access textures having considerable
numbers of transistors dedicated to just this task. This in turn has led to a
huge number of uses for textures. The idea of applying two or more textures has
any number of other uses. For example, a surface can be made visually rich by
giving it textures that add scratches, decals, planetary cloud cover or any
number of other phenomena. Multiple textures can be combined by addition,
multiplication or other operations and all affect the same attribute. Mirror
reflection can be done by rendering from a different angle and then using the
reflected image as a texture used at each pixel. This is a whole huge sub
category where a scene is rendered, and then its resulting image is post
processed in various ways. We'll talk a bit more about these when we get into
shader programming. Because three.js is a web component, it can interact in
interesting ways with other data. For example, you can take a video and use it
as a texture. This texture can then be placed on multiple moving screens as
shown in this demo. Now that you know the basics of texture mapping, you're
equipped to go ahead and dig into other people's demos and see what makes them
tick. Better yet, you can not try out some of your own effects. Texturing is a
powerful tool and I look forward to seeing what you do with it.